in this video we're going to be talking
about proper pipetting technique
now okay that doesn't make sense proper
pie tint the proper pipetting technique
or
a proper pipetting technique no proper
pipetting technique is correct
techniques
no technique like say the sentence again
today we're going to be talking about
proper pipetting technique uh a proper
pipette no it's not a it's a it's a it's
a suite of techniques which makes it
techniques plural today we're going to
be talking about proper pipetting
techniques
are you sure first thing you're gonna
need to do you're gonna need to find
some pipette tips right am i right
that's a horrible joke but you couldn't
get pipette tips you just couldn't get
any you couldn't get them during govid
all right now you can get them but
before you couldn't get them but now you
can get them so we're going to go
through how to prop how to pipette
properly so that you're getting the most
accurate results there's a lot of bad
things that come from not pipelining
correctly you're dispensing the wrong
volumes you know this is the very simple
basic part of your assay but you mess up
here everything downstream from here is
trash and sometimes the reagents and the
things that you're pipetting or your
sample are super precious so you get
that wrong that could be a catastrophe
especially for quantitation and whatnot
so the goal for this video is to figure
out how to get pipetting right as much
as possible the first thing you're going
to want to do is make sure your
pipetting angle is correct so here we
have a scintillation vial with some
water in there you want to make sure
when you're pipetting you're going
straight in okay you don't want to be
going out on a side on the side this is
going to cause issues right and then
when you come up you know it's a good
practice to drag along the side the
second thing you're going to want to do
is you want to make sure everything is
at
ambient temperature or
consistent temperature because we're
dealing with volumes here so typically
colder temperatures will contract the
volume hotter temperatures will expand
the volume so if you want volume to be
consistent you don't want to be handling
some pipette tips by hand and have
different temperature fluctuations or do
assays at different temperatures like in
a hot room in a cold room because that's
all going to affect your volume so
pipetting volume is the second thing the
third thing you want to do is pre-wet
your pipette tip if you can this is a
pretty good practice so what pre-wetting
your pipette means is you put your
pipette in
and you suck and spit a few full-time a
few times and that kind of coats or
lubricates the surface so that when you
actually do pipette your sample
you can get a nice pipette you know see
that
so pre-wetting is a is a good practice
the fourth thing is you want to examine
for any droplets so when you're
pipetting and you like do a quick
dispense you can see there's some
droplets in there so sometimes if you're
dispensing too quickly you're gonna have
a little bit of residual volume in there
that's gonna be taking away from the
volume you should have dispensed watch
out for droplets the fifth thing is make
sure you have proper pipetting rhythm
it's all about the motion of the ocean
right so just make sure like when you're
pipetting you're doing everything smooth
and steady you're pipeating the same way
because like as you saw earlier if you
pipette too fast or you you know you
might not dispense the right amount of
liquid so just making sure that
everything is done slowly and smoothly
so for pipetting here
you know and pipe it back down
and check for droplets so that smooth
rhythm is going to lead to very
consistent results that's why you see
sometimes different operators even
though they're all doing the same thing
that the results are different some
texts run an assay and it's great and
other texts run an assay it's
not so great even though they're running
the same method a lot of it has to do
with the rhythm the sixth thing is to
make sure you use the correct pipette
tip so learning when to use a filter tip
when to use a non-filter tip and the
volumes are really important too could i
pipet 15 microliters in a two to two
hundred microliter pipette tip i could
but do i want to not really you want to
make sure that the volume you select is
within the range of the pipette tip that
you're buying if you can get a closer
range the better so if i'm pipetting 30
microliters say i could use a 250 or a
200 to 200 but i would rather use the 50
microliter pipette because it's going to
be closer to that range the tighter the
range the better the last thing is to
learn when to use forward pipetting or
reverse pipetting you're like what is
forward and reverse pipetting like
you don't really use reverse pipetting
too much forward pipetting is the
standard pipetting technique you'd be
surprised people even get this wrong so
with the pipette there's two stops first
stop second stop when you're doing four
pipe hitting you wanna go in
to the first stop
aspirate up
and then when you dispense you wanna go
to the first stop
and then second stop
and then come all the way back up that's
forward pipetting if you're doing
reverse pipetting this is if you're
working with extra viscous
solutions 99 of the time you're doing
forward pipetting but for the few
percent of the time you're working with
something extra vigorous you go all the
way
ask extra viscous okay you go all the
way down to the second stop so look i'm
depressed all the way go all the way
down to the second stop
i go in
i pet all the way up so now i have
excess volume in here and then i just go
down to the first stop
see that how much volume i've left over
and then you could dispense this back
into it if it's all the same thing or
you can eject the tip so that's forward
pipetting versus reverse pipetting
there's a few other like
methods but like we really don't need to
get into that that pretty much covers
everything hopefully that was helpful
for you hopefully you learned a thing or
two if you hire a new tech and you don't
want to explain pipetting for the 30th
time make them watch this video and
i saved you some time but either way if
you found that helpful you know like
subscribe follow and i'll see you in the
proper next techniques
about proper pipetting techniques
i'll see in the next video about
no we just did proper pipetting
techniques
[Music]
techniques techniques
whatever
proper pipetting techniques
proper my cameraman's a smart ass see
you in the next one
where we'll be talking about
how to pick a pipette tip
how to pick the right pipette tip for
your assay
how to pick
no
[Music]
you